[Music]
on this sunday night emergency in
british columbia
an evacuation order expands as a
wildfire triples in size hot and dry
conditions will continue to challenge
our firefighters and temperatures
continue to break records
mass evacuation in ukraine
hundreds of thousands ordered to leave
as russia bombards the eastern donetsk
region
new york issues a disaster emergency we
are at a very scary place why it may be
too late to contain the spread of monkey
pox
and two montreal boys charity lemonade
stand squeezed by the long arm of the
law
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us we
begin in the west where more than 5
million canadians are under heat
warnings tonight environment canada
issuing notices for swaths of southern
bc and southern alberta temperatures
range anywhere from the high 20s to the
mid 30s and it gets worse the further
you are from the water officials are
warning people to watch out for heat
stroke or heat exhaustion
concern is perhaps greatest on the fire
line the bc wildfire service is battling
more than 60 wildfires in the province
including this one near caramias in the
province's southern interior residents
of more than 20 properties have been
told to leave immediately another 350
are being warned they may have to leave
at a moment's notice the blaze is almost
four and a half square kilometers in
size and is being described as
aggressive and erratic firefighters are
being hampered by steep rugged areas and
of course the weather
initially we thought potentially the
weather would go back to a bit of a
cooler pattern next week right now it's
looking like that might not be the case
so that hot and dry conditions will
continue to challenge our firefighters
and then of course when we start to see
those gusty or spotty winds and areas of
the province that also really drives
fire growth as well
parts of the u.s are also being hit hard
by wildfires firefighters are struggling
to get a handle on a fire burning near
the california-oregon border it has
nearly doubled in size this weekend
growing to more than 20 000 hectares the
flames have forced thousands of
residents to flee their homes a state of
emergency has been declared in the
region
to another emergency now this one
happening in ukraine president vladimir
zelinsky has ordered a mandatory
evacuation of the donetsk region in the
countries east it's believed more than
200 000 people are still living there as
ross lord reports it comes as concern
grows that focus on the war is fading in
canada more than five months after it
began
ukraine even signs of hope are tainted
by the horrors of war the port city of
mick alive enduring its heaviest russian
shelling ever an attack that damaged two
schools and several other buildings and
killed the man whose company worked in
grain exports this as ukraine grain
shipments are about to resume even with
the harvest that could be cut in half
since russia's invasion there's a severe
shortage of storage capacity this
ukrainian farmer says other countries
are not doing enough to help the grain
industry in other regions there are more
urgent priorities
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
ordering a mandatory evacuation of
donetsk region where fighting is intense
saying the more people leave donetsk the
fewer people the russian army will be
able to kill
elsewhere a drone explosion hit the
headquarters of russia's black sea fleet
reportedly injuring six people
more than five months after vladimir
putin's invasion leaders of canada's 1.3
million strong ukrainian community say
it's important canadians don't let their
attention drift away from the war
we do understand
how i you know don't want to be trites
but sort of the fickleness of the
western mind
to what extent
things get to be forgotten mankind does
not learn from its mistakes
and we all too often move on to the next
tragedy they're grateful canada has
contributed to sanctions against russia
military aid for ukraine and has
welcomed scores of people forced to flee
their country
they hope the gruesome ongoing war
doesn't cause the canadian public and
political leaders to lose interest
ross lord global news
grain silos damaged in the devastating
beirut port explosion two years ago
partially collapsed earlier today
the silos had been on fire for weeks
prompting concerns the damaged
structures would fall officials say the
fire was difficult to extinguish it
comes nearly two years since the
warehouse exploded killing more than 200
people and devastating the country to
date no one has been held accountable
for negligently storing chemicals in the
building
more tonight on the staff shortages at
canada's hospitals that appear to be
getting worse by the day there are
closures this weekend at more than a
dozen hospitals in ontario alone as mike
drolet tells us even though the
conditions have been diagnosed there's
no magic cure and even some of the
band-aid solutions aren't working
anymore
canada's ers are being overrun wait
times are getting longer patience is
running thin and healthcare workers are
increasingly overwhelmed nurses are
kicked spit at bitten
it's unbelievable people wouldn't think
that that happens but it happens every
single day the problem as some health
care experts see it is that far too many
canadians look to ers as their go-to for
health care in part because of a
shortage of family doctors
teddy wickland of startup medi-map says
canadians have other options with
specialists in clinics that his website
connects to that are not only open but
mostly free of lineups you know without
tools and technologies like this
patients you know might google and not
know that there's a clinic literally a
block from them that has availability
and they just end up missing that
because there's so much sort of opacity
in the system it's just really hard to
see it you can find in books same day or
next day appointments is it the solution
no but they believe they can at least
ease the burden on ers similar to how
virtual visits did in early 2020.
pre-pandemic under one percent of all
doctor appointments were virtual by
april 2020 necessity saw that number
rise to 70 percent as offices opened the
percentage dropped and now as wait times
have increased maple health whose
services are not covered by all
provincial health plans estimates
virtual is back up to around 40 percent
our last couple of months have been i
would say amongst the busiest that we've
seen since the beginning of the pandemic
however the college of physicians and
surgeons in several provinces most
notably ontario quebec and bc has
tightened the rules around virtual care
warning doctors that if something goes
wrong in a virtual appointment and
they're unable to see that patient in
person they could be guilty of
professional misconduct but what we're
seeing now is a lot of doctors saying
i'm not willing to see that patient
that's in sudbury
because if i can't fully solve their
issue there's no way that i'm going to
be able to physically see them in my
office and so we're seeing a lot of
physicians really be
much more limited in terms of what
they're willing to treat
and that he says is putting limits on a
health care system that needs all the
help it can get
mike trolley global news toronto
public health concerns are also rising
in the u.s as more cities declare
emergencies over the spread of monkey
pox with infections skyrocketing across
the country washington now faces
criticism that it's done too little too
late to contain the disease and as
jennifer johnson reports fears are also
spreading for countless american
students preparing to return to class
with vaccines still widely unavailable
cases of monkey pox are skyrocketing in
the u.s the centers for disease control
is now reporting almost 5 200 cases new
york and san francisco the nation's hot
spots don't have enough vaccines to stop
the spread leading to criticism the
federal government has lost its chance
to contain the virus we are seeing a lot
of parallels of what happened with hiv
aids right like a slow government
response that's really unfortunate to
see the government initially was only
vaccinating people who had known contact
with monkey pox a strategy now seen as a
failure we are at a very scary place
and
we don't want to be ignored by the
federal government in our need monkey
pox is rapidly spreading into the
general population by skin-to-skin
contact and even respiratory droplets as
people let down their guard about covet
19 and attend more gatherings this virus
is now getting into family circumstances
it can spread to women and in close
family contacts where there is a lot of
hugging and kissing doctors are also
sounding the alarm to college students
predicting outbreaks of monkey pox on
campuses this fall
i think it's definitely possible for
college campuses to be the next hot spot
it's obviously an area where there's a
lot of close contact you know living in
dorms so there's also tends to be a lot
more sexual activity while some students
know little or nothing about the virus
others are vowing to take precautions
i'm going to make sure i'm doing
everything i can to stay informed and
stay healthy and clean monkey pox is
rarely fatal but can lead to weeks of
debilitating illness
it is the most painful thing i've ever
experienced in my 47 years on this
planet while it's too late for some the
biden administration is now promising to
distribute hundreds of thousands of
vaccines over the next few weeks
scrambling to stop the spread of this
painful disease
jennifer johnson global news washington
a lack of data has forced the national
institute on aging to pause its kobit 19
tracking project in long-term care
centers dr samir sinha the agency's
director of health policy research says
a lack of data does not allow for a
comparison on how different provinces
are coping it also makes it hard to
monitor how effective their responses
are or what else needs to be done
we don't have really good data
in every province and territory any
longer that allows us to do apples to
apple's comparisons so we actually
understand how different provinces are
currently coping within their long-term
care retirement home settings and that
allows us to compare and contrast and
also look at how canada's performing
against the rest of the world
dr cena says not reporting data can
cause a lack of confidence in how things
are being handled amongst canadians
coming up why police bust a kid's
lemonade stand run to raise money for
the children's ailing mother
it's a summertime rite of passage for
many kids a lemonade stand but two
montreal boys trying to raise research
money for a disease afflicting their
mother ended up with a bitter taste in
their mouths when police put the squeeze
on their stand dan spector explains
thank you so much for the second
straight weekend brothers ariel and nes
partus masa are selling lemonade on the
front lawn of their home in montreal's
west island to raise money for the
multiple sclerosis society of canada if
we give a bunch of money to the charity
we can find a cure for multiple
sclerosis
the cause is very close to the hearts of
both boys their mother ayanna was
diagnosed with the degenerative disease
in 2020 every day is a fight
but having these kinds of kids how do i
not fight for them their secret recipe
has helped raise more than fifteen
hundred dollars even the local bus
driver is on board
but things took an unfortunate and
unexpected turn on saturday to have such
a beautiful story
turn into such a nightmare disaster like
it did yesterday
i was shaking the mother says the boys
were periodically using a megaphone to
attract customers and one angry man he
said you little mother effort i'm going
to shut you down so i told him to get
the hell off my property and he said i'm
calling the police minutes later she
says police arrived and told her the
stand must be shut down i tell him look
officer give me a fine i'll pay the fine
he said oh i'm not giving you a fine you
think that because you're in a
wheelchair you're above the law she says
the officer threatened to arrest her so
she started recording honest to god like
is this normal the guy had his hand on
his holster
telling me that i'm aggressive
and i told him to get off my property he
refused three hours later she says
police left well it ended with this
sergeant telling me my kids are not
allowed to have their megaphone and that
they don't want to have to come back
here and arrest me montreal police told
global news they would not be in a
position to comment on the case on
sunday explaining more analysis is
needed before they issue any kind of
statement always remain calm this
ex-police officer wonders if the mother
escalated the situation he says police
will rarely put an end to lemonade sales
without a permit in that case it's not
necessarily the action on your property
but
the distraction or the problem it causes
the mother is demanding an apology from
montreal police neighbors dropped by to
show the boys support on sunday as they
sold lemonade without their megaphone
dan specter global news montreal
i had the extreme lengths and distance a
pc woman is going to to try to renew a
nexus pass
you're watching global national
[Music]
nexus offices across canada remain
closed and there's no word on when they
may reopen hundreds of thousands of
canadians are waiting to have their
applications processed but those who've
received notice to book an interview can
only do so in u.s centers as richard
zusman explains that's forced one family
to take extreme measures to renew a
nexus guard before it expires
getting to the fast lane grinding to a
halt my daughter's nexus is coming due
for the expiry in september 2022 so
we're desperate now because we have no
idea what's going to happen during the
pandemic barbara cullen's daughter eon
had her nexus card expire after an
automatic two-year renewal due to kovitt
the card is now set to expire for good
in the fall worries no nexus will make
it extremely hard to visit cullen's
widowed mother in washington state the
problem is we go across the border a
number of times
a month because my mother is a widow
down there and roloff found that she has
so i don't want to be able to
i don't have to wait in line right now
none of the nexus centers are open in
canada and getting an appointment in the
u.s is verging on impossible so out of
desperation colin's booked the one
appointment she could find meaning in
september she will be flying with her
daughter from vancouver to winnipeg
driving across the border to tiny war
road minnesota conducting the renewal
appointment then driving back to
winnipeg before flying home what i'm
even worried about is she goes to
interview and she they have about two
weeks to now approve it so what if they
don't even approve after the interview
i'm not even sure it's going to work so
it might just be money down the drain
collins is far from alone right now
there are 341
688 nexus applications waiting to be
processed once a card expires the person
is put back at the end of the line
patrick aiu has been trying to book an
interview since 2019
with no luck
you just along for the ride you can't
um you know it's out of my hands like i
just have to wait until they they say
yes now you can do interviews or no
we're just gonna have to restart this
whole process all over again so it just
seems a bit frustrating
one of the main reasons canadian renewal
centers are not open is because of a
dispute between the u.s and canada
canadian officials do not want to allow
american officials to carry guns at
nexus renewal centers in this country
there are legitimate shortages of labor
all over the place in every industry so
we can be somewhat sympathetic to that
but having some kind of dispute like
this keep offices closed just makes no
sense to me i just google in uh back to
collins she has one more complication
like many
they're still waiting on a passport
hoping eons arrives just before their
planned trip richard lisbon global news
victoria
next why for some canadian athletes the
commonwealth games mean more than the
olympics
in birmingham england team canada is on
a roll at this year's commonwealth games
with more than a dozen medals so far
including three gold overall more than
260 canadian athletes are taking part
across 18 sports and five parasport
events for many their disciplines won't
be showcased on bigger stages like the
olympics or paralympics which as redmond
shannon reports makes these games
special
in 1930 hamilton ontario hosted the
inaugural british empire games and it
may do so again for the 2030 centenary
of what is now known as the commonwealth
games
this year's host birmingham is another
city with a tradition of heavy industry
now looking to use the games as part of
its regeneration my recommendation to
hamilton would certainly be to go for it
because it has genuinely been looks to
have been good economically but also it
is wonderful in terms of the sense of
confidence and pride in the place
[Laughter]
like the pan am games the commonwealth
games can be seen as a springboard to
the olympics but for athletes in
non-olympic or paralympic sports it's
much more than that this is a great
opportunity to
to meet athletes from all different
disciplines
as well and be in the the athletes
village where yeah you're around a whole
bunch of canadians from yeah all
different backgrounds and different
sports and yeah it's a it's an
unbelievable experience toronto lawn
bowler kelly mccarrahan is the most
commonwealth of athletes she lives in
australia and is engaged to a team new
zealand bowler we do get to see each
other every once in a while but yeah at
the end of the day it's all about team
canada for this event
another canadian with a commonwealth
connection is national squash champion
holly norton she moved to ontario from
england as a kid for me it actually
feels more like a home games and i've
got a bunch of family coming down to
watch
while i'm competing my mom and dad are
flying over as well so for me it is like
a home games even though it's not which
is a very nice feeling as it is my first
games as well norton splits her squash
season between the uk and canada so
she's been able to share some local
knowledge with teammates her hope is to
equal or better the silver and bronze
medals she's won at the pan am level for
myself the commonwealth games is kind of
that step up from there and to meddle
here would i mean absolute world to me
and something that i've been working
towards for
quite quite a few years now unlike the
olympics parasports take place in
parallel with the other events the games
run through august 8th redmond shannon
global news london
the more news from the world of sport
nba legend bill russell has died
russell's family says he passed away
peacefully earlier today with his wife
janine by his side russell is considered
one of the most prolific champions in
sports history an 11-time nba champion
an olympic gold medalist and was the
first black head coach in professional
sports he was also considered a civil
rights hero participating in the 1963
march on washington and defending
muhammad ali when he refused to serve in
the military during the vietnam war
because of his religious beliefs bill
russell was 88.
and some sad news out of hollywood
tonight star trek actress nichelle
nichols has died
you running a nursery lieutenant oh
captain
well i hadn't intended to sir but the
triple had other plans
nichols rose to fame playing
communications officer uhura in the
1960s tv series and in the movies that
followed she also earned accolades for
breaking racial stereotypes and made
headlines for an interracial kiss on
screen
with co-star william shatner that was
unheard of at the time michelle nichols
was 89
and that's global national for this
sunday i'm colleen christie we leave you
tonight with a celebration of lgbtq2
plus communities that's making a
long-awaited return in vancouver
[Applause]
after a three-year pandemic hiatus
vancouverites of all identities packed
downtown and west end streets with love
and colors for the city's pride parade
back in full force today its chosen
theme for this year is also appropriate
it's simply together again thanks for
watching we leave you tonight with more
sights and sounds of pride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you